highlight war ein zuschauer haben wir
wieder das ist jetzt einfach schade dass
in dem moment einfach funktioniert jetzt
schon jetzt nicht wie kann das so aus
dass hier noch mal neu machen weil du
raus gegangen bist aus dem bingens das
war dumm stellen kann jetzt schon 500
follower hatte ich freue mich jetzt mal
wie du das machst
also ja da führen wir alle verloren 200
leute das ist ja hier sind 1400 jetzt
inzwischen schon lieber sie das ding
das lustige ist ja die gibt es nicht mal
die möglichkeit zu sagen
scream beenden das war einfach die seite
weg so verschämt ich weiß jetzt nicht
macht ist dass wir jetzt beendet muss er
sein was ich guck mal auf deinen kanal
was da gerade abgeht also du bist live
mit buch mit buch und ich komme ich auf
videos ja live mit buch und du hast
zwölf minuten video hochgeladen also vor
allem die 36 und einmal 15 minuten
guardiola schon zwei und das einheit
schon 8000 aufrufen
wir wollten eigentlich mal jetzt machen
wir die ganze technik technik technik
kommt auch noch einen des sport offenbar
gelöscht
was wolltest du machen wenn ich jetzt
auch videos wählen
hahahaha da kann sie die löschen
aufgezeichnet leisten und den anderen
endgültig löschen das ist so peinlich
dass entweder endgültig war es nicht
mehr rückgängig und weg damit und das
nach einer demnächst geplant da geht
dann auch um 19 uhr
1902 2018 den unterschiedlichen auf die
leute lange gewartet
neva schlägt der luft rede ich hier 561
aufruft der wird jetzt auch endgültig
das ist jetzt machen genau neu starten
dann könnt ihr das einstellen okay wir
starten das jetzt neu wir müssen uns
jetzt sagen was wir einstellen müssten
ich war zu faul zum wald in dieser
ganzen zeit ist ihr noch keine bessere
titel eingefallen ist nummer 9
ok jetzt müssen orte stopp unten gucken
ob da unten noch etwas mit chat steht
später plant nein es ist nicht speziell
für kinder sammeln
[Gelächter]
warte stopp ja das ist ne das ist dieses
ganze das ist ich würde das sind ist
schluss wird ja irgendwie ja nee da bin
ich angezeigt
so jetzt kann man hier vielleicht
irgendwas schlüssel name stream analyse
zustand gibt es hier ich was sie gedacht
nein er soll das gleiche liebe
teilnehmer live chat in einem neuen
fenster einstellungen
das war schon ein bisschen mehr jetzt
fiebert rezept bei keiner moderatorin
verwalten fahrers ach komm aber
zeitstempel h okay das ist wirklich nur
das ist eine weitere informationen
wir müssen aber damit klar komm wir
malen doch die ganze zeit und lesen ich
den chat ja ja ja komm ja komm jetzt
kommt er funktioniert doch hier auch
hier und immer mal zwischendurch und man
hinguckt und schnappt man ja ein zwei
dinge mit auf so gut also das baby
wieder aus sobald deiner anderes zum
startenden vorschützen verbinden eben
beim einrichtung zum live stream ist ein
traum aber erst ein paar
so haben sie das jetzt auch zu hause
lassen so da jetzt raus ich verstehe gar
nichts mehr bleibt scheint langsam modus
ja 60 sekunden mit 60 sekunden schon
viel manchmal so 30 oder mach mal so 20
dann hat gehört kein spam
so weißt du weil man will ja trotzdem
noch auch die antworten wenn du was
fragst und manchmal muss man dann 20
sekunden warten dann also eine news
schon lange zu warten
die wm ok ist es nur noch angehen
mach mal hier einrichten
auch jetzt geht es darum so aber du
willst auch gar nicht obs stream du
willst doch das war vorher noch nicht so
machen
360° video und eben kannst hat das auch
nicht so ganz anders war es ganz anders
die gucke mal 2002 hat leute dabei zu
hey ich schon jetzt das fiel ihm auch
funktioniert haben das war zufällig
vielleicht mal ausmachen hier